im hessischen ginsheim gustavsburg bauen
die deutsche bahn und das land hessen
diese neue unterführung kosten sollte
das bauwerk stolze 16 millionen euro
eigentlich denn nach jahrzehntelangen
planungen stellt sich erst nach
baubeginn plötzlich heraus das geld wird
hinten und vorne nicht reichen
jetzt wird der bau mindestens 40
millionen kosten nachhaltiges planen und
bauen sieht anders aus finden die bürger
der fachleute die wir sind jetzt auch
wissen was sie da machen wenn du froh es
drei fahrer auf einmal dabei
herausspringt ja dann war sie sind was
erst der fachleute wenn ich so plant
wäre dann hätte ich schon so ein riesen
problem aber wenn ein mensch aus rund
eur auf einmal 500 euro wird dann fragt
die frau schon was hast du da gemacht
weil die schranken des doppel
bahnübergangs dauernd geschlossen sind
plant man seit mitte der 70er jahre die
bahnunterführung immer wieder wird der
baugrund untersucht und begutachtet aber
als dann endlich im dezember 2016
gegraben wird erlebt man eine böse
überraschung nach der anderen
der lehmige boden ist höchst
problematisch spundwände müssen viel
aufwendiger ins erdreich getrieben
werden
dabei stößt man immer wieder auf schutt
und schrott in keinem der gutachten
taucht dies auf die baukosten
explodieren mit heftigen folgen für die
stadt ihr anteil steigt von knapp
500.000 euro auf rund 1,5 millionen
jetzt ein anstieg von einer million
obendrauf zu stemmen ist für uns als
stadt ginsheim gustavsburg kaum machbar
und möglicherweise muss auch dann der
bürger zur kasse gebeten werden ohne
dass wir als stadt etwas dafür können
aber wer ist für den ganzen schlamassel
verantwortlich etwa die unternehmen die
die bodengutachten erstellt haben der
landesbetrieb hessen mobil teilt uns in
abstimmung mit der deutschen bahn
schriftlich mit regress ansprüche können
nicht geltend gemacht werden da den
ingenieurbüros die die baugrundgutachten
erstellt haben kein schuldhaftes
verhalten nachgewiesen werden kann
mit anderen worten die schuld will
keiner übernehmen die kosten bleiben am
steuerzahler hängen
und das schlimme einer sache ist uns
sind die hände gebunden also wir können
ja eigentlich nicht wirklich etwas
dagegen tun aber wir bezahlen und dann
ist man schon echt wütend
was dann mit dem ganzen geld passiert
das das absolute in den sand geschossen
wird bei den ganzen problemen hängt man
beim zeitplan deutlich hinterher
erst anfang 2021 kann die dringend
benötigte bahnunterführung eröffnet
werden immer vorausgesetzt dass ab jetzt
alles nach plan läuft